aquí dibujé la gráfica de tres funciones
una es fx que pinte en color rojo
después
efe prima de x la derivada en color rosa
y finalmente pinte efe doble prima de x
es decir la segunda derivada en color
morado o bien también podemos pensarla
como la derivada de la primera derivada
además la saline para ver cómo están
relacionadas bueno de lo que hemos
platicado en vídeos pasados ya sabemos
identificar máximos y mínimos a través
de que la derivada se anule y viendo
como cambia de signo por ejemplo en este
punto de acá bueno en este punto la
derivada se hace cero que corresponde
más o menos a a este punto en la gráfica
de fx y aquí tenemos un máximo como
veíamos que era máximo con el cambio de
signos de la derivada pues veíamos que
antes de este punto la función era
creciente era creciente lo cual
correspondía a que la derivada fuera
positiva
y después de ese punto teníamos que la
derivada de la negativa y por tanto que
la función era decreciente
esto nos indicaba que aquí teníamos un
máximo local nada más local verdad a lo
mejor ésta crece mucho por acá de manera
similar en este punto otra vez aquí la
derivada se anula es un punto crítico
entonces corresponde más o menos a este
punto de acá y ahora tenemos un mínimo
que se puede identificar viendo que
primero la derivada es negativa es decir
que la función es decreciente y luego al
cruzar el punto la derivada cambia de
signo cambia de negativo a positivo y
por tanto la función ahora se hace
decreciente y eso es un indicador de que
aquí tenemos un punto mínimo muy bien
entonces lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
hacer un poquito más sofisticado nuestro
análisis de mínimos y de máximos
metiendo un concepto que se llama
concavidad déjame escribirlo por acá lo
voy a poner en color si este color rojo
está bien le voy a poner aquí concavidad
nunca vi
o ponerla de más grande concavidad muy
bien básicamente la idea la idea de la
concavidad es que vamos a utilizar la
segunda derivada para identificar
máximos y mínimos en vez de ver el
cambio del signo de la primera derivada
entonces vamos a analizar un poquito qué
sucede con las regiones donde está el
máximo y el mínimo ya platicar cómo se
va moviendo la derivada porque pues cómo
se mueve la derivada es como es la
segunda derivada va entonces la derivada
aquí al principio bueno déjame dibujar
las las rectas tangentes la derivada
pues más o menos pero en la recta
tangente es como así verdad que tiene
una pendiente es más o menos grande es
positiva pero conforme vamos avanzando
hacia la derecha tenemos que la derivada
que es menor y por tanto la pendiente es
menor
luego la pendiente es menor menor menos
y menos positiva hasta llegar a este
punto en el punto crítico la derivada se
hace cero y luego se empieza a ser
negativa empieza a ser negativa y cada
vez más y más negativa y más y más
negativa hasta que llegamos a este punto
de acá donde está el mínimo de la deriva
sale entonces en toda esta región que le
pasó a la derivada a la derivada empezó
siendo grande y bajo bajo bajo bajo o
sea también se ve aquí verdad peso
siendo positiva menos menos positiva 0
negativa negativa y baja y baja y baja
es decir tenemos que la derivada la
deriva decreciente en esta región de acá
y como la deriva desde creciente
entonces la segunda derivada es menor
que cero entonces le voy a poner que
aquí la deriva desde creciente y por
tanto la segunda derivada en esta región
en esta región es menor que cero déjame
cambiar de color a este color como como
amarillo pastel entonces ahora vamos a
la segunda región donde está el mínimo
entonces en esta región donde está el
mínimo ahora la derivada tiene un cierto
valor ahorita es negativo pero conforme
nos acercamos a este punto la derivada
va creciendo crece crece al llegar aquí
se hace cero y luego sigue creciendo
crece y crece y crece más salen entonces
empezó siendo negativa y después creció
también se ve aquí en la gráfica de la
es negativa crece 0 positiva y sigue
creciendo y por lo tanto como la como la
derivada como la derivada ahora es
creciente creciente eso en términos de
la segunda derivada es que es mayor que
0 va ahora aquí la de ayudad es mayor
que cero a la izquierda tenemos como una
forma de boca abajo y a la derecha
tenemos una forma de boca arriba bueno
esta forma de boca abajo y de boca
arriba tienen un nombre entonces a esto
se le llama justo como es la concavidad
entonces déjame escribirlo con este
color verde va entonces si tenemos que
la gráfica aparece así como una volteada
como una uva hacia abajo ya que la
gráfica abre hacia abajo
a esto se le dice que es cóncavo hacia
abajo cóncavo hacia abajo hacia abajo
abajo sale o bien que la gráfica es
cóncava hacia abajo va por otro lado si
tenemos una forma de un sí o sea como
que la funcionase como una bus y abre
hacia arriba estoy acá se le conoce como
cóncavo cóncavo
hacia hacia arriba
arriba
muy bien entonces ya tenemos cóncavo
hacia abajo y tenemos cóncavo hacia
arriba vamos a escribir esto por acá
vale entonces como como bueno vamos a
reescribir todas las cosas que ya
sabemos qué sucede si tenemos una
función que es cóncava hacia abajo
cóncava
cabo hacia
abajo
a abajo entonces a ver si es cóncavo
hacia abajo eso quiere decir que la
derivada que la derivada va decreciendo
verdad entonces pues vamos a ponerlo así
o sea que sea cóncavo hacia abajo es lo
mismo que decir que la pendiente la
pendiente
es decreciente decreciente eso en
términos de la primera derivada quiere
decir que f prima de x es decreciente no
me lo voy a poner así decreciente y
entonces en términos de la segunda
derivada eso es que ese doble prima de x
sea menor que cero verdad una función es
decreciente si su derivada es menor que
cero aquí la función es f prima por lo
tanto sus derivadas f doble prima de x
la segunda derivada de f muy bien ahora
vámonos con cóncavo hacia arriba cóncavo
cóncavo asia
arriba
rival
sale entonces con cóncavo hacia arriba
ahora lo que tenemos en esta región de
acá es que la pendiente es creciente la
pendiente
es creciente es creciente
gente lo cual quiere decir que f prima
de x es creciente va a poner así
creciente lo cual quiere decir que la
segunda derivada ahora no es menor que
cero sino mayor que cero muy bien
entonces ya tenemos cóncavo hacia abajo
y cóncavo hacia arriba como le podemos
hacer para utilizando estos términos o
estas ideas identificar si un punto
crítico es mínimo o es máximo bueno pues
déjame hacer nada más los pequeños
dibujos o sea cóncavo hacia abajo se ve
como una n chinos o quedó muy chueco es
como una n cóncava hacia arriba es como
una y entonces qué sucede si tenemos que
algo bueno una región en donde una
función es cóncava hacia abajo y además
tenemos un punto crítico imagínate que
es cóncava hacia abajo y además de esto
tenemos que en un punto a efe de a efe
es igual a cero a pues en esta región
tenemos una boca abajo es decir la
pendiente va disminuyendo y disminuyendo
eso que quiere decir que la función al
principio es creciente la llega
aquí se hace cero y luego la función es
decreciente y por tanto si tenemos
cóncava hacia abajo y además tenemos que
f es igual a cero si tenemos un punto
crítico esto implicaría implica que a es
máximo bueno que tenemos un valor máximo
de manera similar si tenemos cóncavo
hacia arriba se ve como una u
entonces aquí abajo vamos a tener que es
un mínimo verdad pero dicho de otra
forma
ahora tenemos que la pendiente es
creciente pero como pasa por cero al
principio de la función era decreciente
verdad la función
efe era decreciente y luego se hace
creciente entonces si tenemos que f
prima de x es mayor que 0 y además
tenemos que f
y es igual a cero si ahora tenemos un
punto crítico tenemos que a
es un
niño muy bien